pierre mendès-france est mort ce matin
la france vient de perdre des plus
grands de ses fils a déclaré le chef de
l'état
assemblée nationale les députés
examinent le projet de réforme de la
sécurité sociale la sphère du choral les
trois responsables du centre pour
enfants handicapés qui aurait été
entraîné dans des bals et bleu inculpés
et écroués explosion d'un silo de grains
à metz au moins trois morts plusieurs
blessés
la raison et la paix longtemps porté
après des journées et des nuits de dures
négociations charge et entourent
d'anxiété tantôt d'espoir le cessez le
feu a été signé en exposerait demain le
contenu à l'assemblée nationale dès
maintenant vous en connaissez les
clauses essentielles
il en est qui sont cruels mais nous
devons à nos soldats qui ont tenu là bas
dans des situations souvent tragiques
d'avoir conclu à des conditions qui
permettront à la france de continuer
dans la paix a joué son rôle en
extrême-orient
en mon âme et conscience j'ai la
certitude que ces conditions sont les
meilleurs que nous pouvions espérer dans
l'état réseau des choses
madame monsieur bonsoir la rigueur la
rectitude la passion contenu la fermeté
dans ses convictions dans cette voie que
vous venez d'entendre celle d'un homme
de 47 ans alors au faîte du pouvoir qui
vient d'annoncer à la radio aux français
la paix en indochine dans cette voix
vibre la personnalité d'un homme pierre
mendès-france qui n'aura jamais exercé
le pouvoir que sept mois et qui pourtant
aura marqué son temps pierre
mendès-france est mort ce matin à l'âge
de 75 ans en son domicile parisien
il est mort semble-t-il d'un arrêt
cardiaque en pleine conversation
téléphonique
l'image publique qui nous reste de
l'huile
dernière le plus émouvante aussi date du
21 mai dernier le président mitterrand
le jour de son investiture avait tenu à
lui rendre hommage c'est grâce à vous
que ceci a été possible avait il dit à
cet homme longtemps à part sur la scène
politique française qu'il dominait
pourtant d'une sorte de poids moral
le chef de l'état dès le début de
l'après midi a été l'un des premiers à
aller s'incliner devant la dépouille
mortelle de pierre mendès-france
jean-michel l'air toujours ce dernier
hommage à un ami
le président mitterrand a expressément
voulu taire ses sentiments personnels
je veux simplement dire aux français
que la france vient de perdre
bon
des fans de rendre service le moment
maintenant et je n'eus de méditer nous
parlerons un peu plus tard de sa
compagne ont fait perdu un compagnon un
adieu avec l'en
toute la journée rue collignon se sont
succédé dans le recueillement et la
discrétion
les proches et les amis de l'ancien
président du conseil par milieu françois
loncle qui lui a succédé comme député
gaston monnerville l'ancien président du
sénat et jean pierre bloch président de
la licra
mais aussi marcel bleustein blanchet
l'un de ses compagnons de résistance
tous ont dit leur émotion et leur
surprise
tous ont voulu témoigner de son exemple
de rigueur et de volonté mise au service
de la france
comme il est de règle parfois en
politique c'est dans la mort que les
louanges vont faire l'unanimité autour
de pierre mendès-france
car cet homme qui fut tour à tour en son
temps le plus jeune avocate france le
plus jeune député le plus jeune
secrétaire d'état qui malgré la brièveté
de son passage à la présidence du
conseil sous la quatrième république a
marqué plus d'une génération d'hommes
politiques de hauts fonctionnaires
d'intellectuels français
c'est un homme politique fut aussi l'un
des plus violemment critiqué est l'un
des plus seul
georges bortoli nous en fait le portrait
il avait été avant guerre le plus jeune
avocat de france le plus jeune député de
france le plus jeune membre du
gouvernement léon blum
il allait devenir un 47 ans là les plus
jeunes présidents du conseil de la
quatrième république
en 1954 le grand public connaît pierre
mendès france mais la classe politique
ne le reconnaît pas toujours comme un
des siens elle trouve le député de
l'eure trop solitaire trompe à l'écart
des partys et des sommes trop en marche
cet ancien résistant cet ancien aviateur
de la france libre a démissionné avec
éclat du premier gouvernement de gaulle
depuis lors depuis neuf ans plus le
moindre marocain et le voici
effectivement président du conseil son
programme d'abord mettre fin à la guerre
d'indochine
car la france paye alors laventure de
dien bien phu
cette aventure de dien bien phu lancée
six mois plus tôt avec un si bel
optimisme en ré forces franco
vietnamiennes ont pris une nouvelle fois
l'offensive
voici les images du coup d'audace de
dien bien phu au cours duquel des
milliers de parachutistes ont été
largués au coeur même du dispositif
vietminh en paysage la lutte pour la
possession de la cuvette fut à la fois à
des débits violent l'ennemi du produit
se replier dans les collines
environnantes
ce ton optimiste n'a pas duré bientôt
dien bien phu est complètement coupé du
reste du monde
hormis les parachutages et les appuis
aériens
le 7 mai 1954 ses défenseurs succombe
sous le nombre sous l'acharnement de
leurs adversaires à paris le
gouvernement de monsieur daniel tombe et
c'est alors que mr s france huit succès
il court à genève où siège une
conférence internationale sur l'asie il
n'hésite pas nouveauté révolutionnaire
pour l'époque a engagé les conversations
avec le représentant de la chine
populaire show en live
il s'est donné un mois pour réussir pour
mettre fin au conflit
des américains ont dit dès le début
qu'il ne voulait pas signer un document
où figure et la signature de chinois
puisqu'il ne reconnaissait pas la chine
et nous avions naturellement et tout le
monde avait le plus grand intérêt à ce
que l'accord final engage des américains
ni plus ni moins que tous les autres
alors on a inventé une formule
diplomatique assez particulière assez
original qui est la suivante
le secrétaire général de la conférence a
établi un procès-verbal des points sur
lesquels la corse était fait et il a
donné lecture en séance plénière et puis
chacune des délégations a fait une
déclaration unilatérale pour faire ses
observations pour dire ce qu'il
appréciait una fassiez - mais aussi pour
s'engager à ne pas briser à ne pas
mettre en cause par remettre en cause ce
qui venait d'être proclamée par
conséquent les américains bien que
n'ayant pas signé on prie très
exactement les engagements que nous
pouvions attendre d'eux qu'ils étaient
les mêmes que nous avions pris moon
c'est pourquoi les conventions de genève
n'ont jamais été signé par les
américains ni par personne dans les
accords de genève sont signés le 21
juillet
dix jours plus tard pmf comme on
l'appelle repart pour la tunisie où un
nouveau conflit colonial menace à
carthage il déclare aubey souverain
nominale du petit état que la france
reconnaît à la tunisie son autonomie
interne première étape vers
l'indépendance
il y aura désormais à carthage une rue
mendès-france
mais à paris des adversaires l'attend
partisans de l'empiré partisans de
l'europe adversaires du dirigisme et du
scrutin l'arrondissement mêmes parce
qu'il n'aime pas son verre de lait les
marchands de vin et les bouilleurs de
cru le punch novembre 1954 célébrant
l'anniversaire de l'armistice aux côtés
du président rené coty pierre mendès
france n'est déjà plus qu'un président
du conseil en sursis la france
traditionnelle celle des notables et
même son propre parti le parti radical
qu'il s'attachera un peu plus tard
rénovés sont un peu là d'un style
inhabituel de réforme à la hussarde
trois mois encore et le bon monsieur
coty devra faire appel à un autre
président du conseil février 1955
edgar faure succède à mendès-france qui
a eu le pouvoir sept mois et 17 jours et
qui ne le retrouvera jamais passé à
l'opposition en 1958 il est pour les
gouvernements du général de gaulle un
censeur vigoureuse et rigoureux dont les
discours fortement charpenté sont
toujours écouté avec attention dans
l'hémicycle nous souhaitons aussi que
l'état pratique enfin une véritable
politique des revenus
pas n'importe quelle politique des
revenus pas une politique des revenus
exclusivement limitée aux salaires voire
dirigée contre les salaires mais une
politique qui par une plus grande
honnêteté fiscale par une action
équilibrée sur les prix prix agricoles
prix du secteur nationalisé rick bass
contrôlé par la maîtrise de secteurs
aujourd'hui abandonnée à la spéculation
stimulera la production et du lary 'sera
les flux économiques stabilisera mieux
la conjoncture et assurera une
répartition plus juste des fruits du
travail commun
en mai 68 on reparle de lui les foules
qui déferle dans les rues de paris
semble un moment de voir le tir et de sa
demi retraite
les étudiants sont trop jeunes pour se
souvenir de dien bien phu mais son nom à
gauche est important au stade charléty
on le voit guère
on n'entend pas maison l'acclament de
daglan le regular et billère
le lendemain françois mitterrand propose
que pierre mendès france prenne la tête
d'un gouvernement provisoire tout en
posant sa propre candidature à l'elysée
on va je suis candidat aux élections
présidentielles de 1969
pierre mendès france fera équipe avec
gaston defferre son meeting à grenoble
soulève la passion de la salle vous avez
depuis 10 ans dans ce pays ralentit
l'industrialisation par rapport à nos
voisins
vous avez avantager les catégories déjà
les plus avantagés dans la nation vous
avez mis la monnaie en danger
l'allemagne qui économiquement était
derrière nous nous a maintenant
largement dépassé voilà votre bilan
depuis dix ans et ils peuvent avoir
il
et il faudra voir maintenant que le
temps est venu de changer enfin
d'orientation et du directoire
depuis lors on l'avait moins vu retirer
solitaire solitaire oui il le fut sa vie
durant
et pourtant il a laissé dans notre vie
politique ça marque une marque que
l'accolade de françois mitterrand le 21
mai 1981 à l'elysée a confirmé
pour beaucoup ce baiser a été un moment
historique c'est un moment historique
parce que ce jour là depuis ce jour d'un
certain nombre de chance il était
interdit qu'il était bloquée kit grippe
et sont devenues possibles
jean lacouture vous êtes journaliste
écrivain vous avez écrit une biographie
de pierre mendès-france qui fait
autorité puisqu'elle révèle vraiment une
connaissance intime de de l'homme et de
son époque
comment expliquez vous la place
singulière de pierre mendès-france dans
le paysage politique français
je dirais peut-être d'abord par une
sorte de paradoxe par sa solitude
je pense que les français ont le goût
des personnalités extrêmement
indépendante et à part et le fait que
mendès-france était celui que le général
de gaulle a appelé celui qu'on ne peut
pas appeler celui qui agit par lui-même
et a été un élément de deux lames du
respect qui l'a entouré c'est cet esprit
d'indépendance ombrageuse qui a fait une
partie de sa de sa notoriété et de delà
du respect qui l'entouraient je dirais
aussi qu'il y a ceci que tous ceux qui
ont rencontré ma défense qui l'ont
écouté radio à la télévision et ils ont
toujours été impressionné par le
l'impression de sincérité de conviction
qui se dégageait de lui il ya beaucoup
de gens dans la vie publique ce n'est
pas il n'était pas le seul certes mais
rarement quelqu'un donner l'impression
d'aussi fort de croire à ce qu'il disait
et d'autre part d'être bien décidé à
faire suivre utiliser d'actes et madness
france quand il est venu au pouvoir est
apparu aux yeux des français comme
l'homme qui détenteurs d'un pouvoir s'en
servait que c'était un homme qui était
venue pour gouverner pour agir non pas
pour attendre non pas pour faire des
compromis mais pour
chez dans le vi et prendre des décisions
et ça l'est le peuple croit m
à être gouvernés quand il a choisi ceux
qui le gouvernent et aussi pour leur
faire boire du lait parce qu'il faut
bien dire même si c'est devenu une
anecdote que pierre mendès-france
restera pour beaucoup de français
l'homme qui a essayé de leur faire boire
du lait c'est vrai on ne reste pas
toujours par les plus grands côté de ce
que l'on fait encore qui n'eut rien
certes de méprisable a souhaité diminuer
la consommation d'alcool des français
qui est probablement un des objectifs de
gouvernement permanent et respectable
des bons gouvernements mais aussi en
effet decaudain inciter les enfants des
écoles à boire du lait leur donner les
facilités de le faire au surplus par là
même aider les producteurs de les faire
remonter les cours du lait pour une
paysannerie qui en a bien besoin de tout
cela et étaient les objectifs tout à
fait convenable et comme un test ne ne
négligeait pas certes mais à partir du
moment où l'un des sept entrées dans
l'opposition un peu comme en religion
c'est à dire à partir de 56 à peu près
il ne sait que très rarement engagé dans
la politique française et quand il l'a
fait ce n'était pas toujours avec
beaucoup de bonheur c'est à dire qu'il
viole le font pas de la tentative d'un
présidentielle de 1969 dont demeure te
dis parlais tout à l'heure c'est vrai
mais à part ça la tentative de
résurrection du parti radical d'un parti
radical digne de ce nom était une
entreprise fort louable et il a échoué
en font que parce que les les dirigeants
principaux et ancien du parti ils ont
été empêchés de réussir qu'ensuite il
est tenté de dégager un socialisme à la
française un socialisme moderne dans le
livre la république moderne notamment ou
par l'école l'ocm à grenoble au
qu'ensuite il est tenté de dégager les
conditions d'une nouvelle éducation
nationale notamment colloque de camps
comme suit il est tenté en mai 1970
d'être celui qui n'ont pas parlé mais
essayer de comprendre d'être à l'écouté
de la jeunesse tous homme parfait
parfaitement honorables puisque le la
coalition d'aidé des partis et des
anciens dirigeants
le tenait à l'écart du pouvoir eh bien
il a cherché par la pensée par la
recherche l'action l'écoutent de
comprendre mieux son temps et d'être
mieux à même de lui
de servir la vie publique d'autant plus
qu'à l'époque il participé activement au
ps où il a participé au ps eut en effet
de 1966 à quelques années plus tard
exactement le moment où il a quitté le
ps eut un peu après les quelques
violences de 68 qu'il a acquis la
condamner car s'il est allé au stade
charléty qu'avant l'europôle cela c'est
parce que cette réunion était pour une
fois une réunion légal acceptés par le
gouvernement
où d'ailleurs il ne s'est pas juger en
mesure de prendre la parole parce que
c'était aux jeunes de parler et pas lui
mais où il a voulu être présents pour
témoigner que les hommes de sa
génération était aussi et les hommes qui
cherchait à comprendre ce qui ce se qui
se préparait dans une génération plus
jeune
en tout cas ce soir le monde politique
et syndical français tout entier exprime
son affliction l'assemblée à l'assemblée
nationale car bérégovoy le ministre des
affaires sociales et lui même ancien
collaborateur de pierre mendès-france
lui a rendu hommage au nom du
gouvernement tandis que les députés
observer d'abord une minute de silence
jean-louis le seul jaune avec mes chers
collègues à observer en signe de deuil
une minute de silence le gréement
s'incline
devant la mémoire du président pierre
mendès-france ces jeux récents
personnellement
douloureusement la disparition de celui
qui m'avait accordé sur l'affection et
auxquels je vois fidélité et admiration
déjà dit qu'il s'agissait de la
disparition d'un homme d'état sortant
avec eux
elsa violent et parfois des divergences
mais
non
par exemple
la période de l'apn de chine que pour
laquelle nous avions à lutter sans cesse
qu'ils avaient été obtenus avec
sous sa présidence avoir été menés this
town jours
il a été certainement de tous les hommes
de gouvernement de la 4è public celui
qui le plus la senti la nécessité de
rebâtir les institutions il n'y est pas
parvenu il a même été je crois
la victime la plus éclatante du système
des partis mais il a indiscutablement
shanty cette nécessité
vous savez qu'il a fait des propositions
elles ne correspondent pas à ceux qui
ont été ensuite les institutions de
segment b
mais c'était une idée qui avait au moins
le mérite de trancher avec l'instabilité
qui étaient ces deux extrêmes au public
de tous les hommages qui s'exprime ce
soir de la gauche à la droite
deux exemples le ministre de l'intérieur
gaston defferre et l'ancien premier
ministre raymond barre
c'était un homme absolument
exceptionnelle j'ai effectivement connu
on à la guerre allons alors que j'étais
en mission entre de lune et qui était un
escadrille comme commandant de bord
d'avions qui bombardaient l'allemagne
ils avaient tous l'intelligence la
compétence le courage et c'était un
orateur très maca il a marqué une époque
en 1944 lendemain de la libération il
avait proposé au général de gaulle une
politique économique et financière qui
aurait pu contribuer à sortir la france
de la guerre et des ruines
elle avait accepté deux hommes de choix
et l'a choisi il a démissionné
qui peut oublier le rôle salutaire et
décisif qu'il a joué pendant la période
hélas trop courtes où il dirigea le
gouvernement de la france
son éloignement de la scène politique au
cours de ces dernières années
n'affectera en rien son autorité morale
ni l'audience nationale et
internationale que lui valait ses vues
pénétrantes sur les réalités de la
france et du monde et son sens aigu des
transformations de nos sociétés pendant
toute sa vie le président malaise francs
sera servi avec noblesse la république
et l'état
si l'action politique du président
madness france fut dominée en son temps
par la sphère indochinoise et par les
problèmes économiques il faut dire aussi
jean lacouture que très vite à
l'étranger
il a acquis une stature d'homme d'état
oui on peut dire que aux yeux des
américains par exemple il ya eu trois
français contemporain qui dominaient
leur temps de gaulle jean monnet et
pierre mendès-france
il avait acquis la l'admiration des
américains et même deux hommes comme
forcèrent de l'os qui ne pensait pas
vraiment comme lui notamment sur
l'indochine et de la seule parler de lui
comme d'un superman
ce qui n'était pas du goût de ma
naissance qui ne se prenait pas du tout
pour un superman mais pour un homme
comme les autres peut-être plus attachés
que d'autres aux biens publics
alors le drame du proche-orient fut
jusqu'au bout l'objet de l'attention
douloureuse d'un homme qui en tant que
juifs et en tant que français a voulu
jusqu'au bout et des rats la paix c'est
ainsi qu'en juillet dernier
et en pleine intervention israélienne au
liban il avait appelé à la négociation
entre israël et l'olp et ses
déclarations signé aussi par deux
personnalités du congrès juif mondial
avait provoqué quelques mois dans la
communauté juive de toutes les capitales
étrangères c'est à jérusalem que sa
disparition ce soir provoque le plus
d'émotions comme exprime le chef de
l'opposition travailliste shimon peres
en effet un géant à l'échelle mondiale
un homme extraordinaire personnes on
était absolue par son courage politique
par sont braqués militaire par sans
conscience sociale très unique
il offrira un message pour nous tous je
les considère comme un an tu as les plis
dans les dix plus grands dont deux ne
perd pourtant l'histoire de cette
famille qui commença portugal comment
morand c'est ce que sony dernier un jour
cette année histoire des vies juives
sont biographie ce temps biographie
exemplaires pour chaque personne tibet
cherchait l'imanité son pays que nous
tous
l'un des fidèles de pierre mendès-france
le dessus qui a longtemps travaillé à
ses côtés qui jusqu'à ces derniers jours
encore s'entretenait avec lui l'avocat
georges kiejman raconte à martin
chaussin son dernier ans bien des gens
vont aujourd'hui parler de la grandeur
des choix politiques qu'il a pu exercer
- je vous
dray a insisté sur un aspect mal connue
de lui et qui était que c'était un homme
extrêmement tendre extrêmement généreux
extrêmement attentif à ses amis ce n'est
pas de l'anecdote que le tir parce que
je pense que cette faculté d'attention
qu'il avait lorsqu'il avait à trancher
de la solution d'un grand problème
politique
lui venait de cette faculté d'écouté
exceptionnelle qu'il pouvait avoir à
l'égard de n'importe qui un membre de sa
famille un enfant un ami
rien ne laissait indifférent et ça je
crois que c'était la réconciliation de
la politique et de la générosité
vous l'avez vu il n'ya pas longtemps par
dernière fois c'était quand j'ai vu une
quinzaine de jours mais je lui ai parlé
à propos des événements du moyen-orient
et pour vous citer encore une fois un
exemple qui dépasse l'anecdote je me
suis entretenu avec lui du problème tu
chopes disons pas du problème que posait
la nouvelle sur les camps de sabra et
chatila et il m'a répondu par quelques
réflexions politiques et comme j'étais
en fait assez désarçonné par cette
approche des choses il a pressenti que
au fond je n'avais pas reçu ce besoin de
secours affectif que j'attendais de lui
et à huit heures du soir six heures plus
tard il a pris la peine de me rappeler
uniquement parce qu'il sentait que un
ami était dans un désarroi moral il ne
remplissait pas une mission politique il
n'écrivait pas un article de journal
simplement il aidé un ami sur un
problème important pour cette année
justement jean lacouture georges kiejman
via d'y faire allusion parlons un peu de
la de la chaleur de l'humour est aussi
du charme de pierre mendès-france
oui le mot je pense n'est pas n'est pas
déplacée aujourd'hui je pense que même
sans cette aide dès ma naissance et mené
une très grande d'une très grande
humanité union pour on pouvait sentir en
lui non seulement cette sincérité dont
je parlais tout à l'heure cette
conviction mais aussi une sensibilité à
fleur de peau c'était un homme
extrêmement sensible je dirais même un
homme fragile
et les les haines dont il a été l'objet
les insultes dont il a été abreuvé lui
était extraordinairement
extraordinairement cruel il savait les
surmonter parce qu'il avait du courage
et il avait voulu dire employer le mot
ce charme cette séduction qui venait
peut-être de la façon dont il savait
écouter les autres et aussi d'une voix
très belle que les français ont bien
connu dans au cours de ces fameuses
allocution radio diffusant tda elle a
été l'inventeur en france qu'il avait
d'ailleurs commencé sous le premier
gouvernement du général de gaulle en
1945 qu'il a reprises pendant son
gouvernement 1954 et qui étaient des
modèles de clarté et de et de
vulgarisation respectueuse de la pensée
des autres ça c'était c'était ma défense
je crois l'aptitude à comprendre les
autres à les écouter et à tenter de les
convaincre c'était un homme de
conviction de ses convictions à lui est
un homme qui voulait faire de partager
ses convictions leurs nombreux sont ceux
qui des anciens de l'hebdomadaire
l'express à une bonne partie du
personnel politique français dont
certains sont au pouvoir maintenant pour
être encore et vont encore évoqué le
personnage mades mais en dernier hommage
pour ce soir écoutons comment lui même
faisait le bilan de son action en juin
80 quand il était l'invité de notre
journal je crois que l'action de nos
politiques ne se juge pas uniquement par
le fait qu'il a été pendant un certains
nombres de d'un certain nombre de mois à
la tête du gouvernement ou
responsabilités ministérielles la vie
d'un homme politique est beaucoup plus
complexe et beaucoup plus longue
en fait j'ai exercé mon activité
politique pendant de nombreuses années
de dizaines d'années même si je n'ai été
effectivement à la tête du gouvernement
que pendant un temps limité
le reste du temps ça a été un combat
pour du conviction pour des idées qui
étaient les miennes pour faire prévaloir
pour faire mourir
certaines heures certitude que je
ressentais profondément pour persuader
ceux qui m'écoutait
certains qu'il faisait confiance
d'autres qui très sincèrement jugé
autrement et le bilan d'une vie
politique ce n'est pas seulement le
bilan d'une action au pouvoir c'est je
crois le bilan d'un très long combat qui
dépasse très largement les limites
la chronologie des deux gouvernements
d'être nommé en hommage à pierre
mendès-france antenne 2 lui consacrera
une émission spéciale jeudi prochain
jeudi à 20h35 l'émission sera animée par
joseph pasteur à l'assemblée nationale
je vous le disais tout à l'heure la
séance de cet après-midi s'est donc
ouverte sur un hommage à monsieur
mendès-france hommage prononcé au nom du
gouvernement par pierre bérégovoy
le ministre des affaires sociales
défendez devant les députés son projet
de réforme de la sécurité sociale
jean-louis le scène dans l'état actuel
du projet de loi gouvernemental le moins
que l'on puisse dire c'est que les
députés socialistes accueille le plan
bérégovoy du bout des lèvres
principal point de désaccord
l'imposition des pré-retraités réponse
du ministre on peut trouver un terrain
d'entente
à condition toutefois que l' équilibre
du budget de la sécurité sociale soit
respectée aujourd'hui père soit 7000
francs paye but pour censure soit 140
francs
à salariés qui gagnent sept mille francs
paye 700 francs voilà ce qui nous avait
conduits à penser qu'un effort
d'harmonisation devait être accompli
seulement nous nions pas du tout que le
pré retraités a pris sa retraite par
anticipation
alors le parlement propose des
améliorations
il propose d'atténuer le coût de la
mesure et nous en sommes d'accord sous
réserve ainsi que je les dis qu'à une
diminution des ressources correspondent
soit une économie souhaite une autre
recette
parce que c'est le devoir du
gouvernement de garantir la sécurité
sociale l'udf comme le rpr ne votera pas
ce projet de loi l'ancien ministre de la
santé pense d'ailleurs que les mesures
envisagées ne serviront à rien le
chantier s'est beaucoup dégradée en 15
mois
le rythme des dépenses est accélérée
telle manière que les recettes prévues
aujourd'hui dont certaines d'ailleurs
sont contestables je pense aux frais
retraité nous suffiront bon pour boucher
les trous qui ont été creusés les
communistes également ne sont pas très
chauds en plus du problème des pré
retraités ils s'opposent au forfait
hospitalier de 20 francs par jour ce que
nous souhaitons puisque nous avons des
amendements c'est que nos gouvernements
les c'est ce que j'ai dit en terminant
eh bien nous souhaitons que nous soyons
entendus et compris
alors ça ça peut aller bien aujourd'hui
jusqu'à l'obsession
le débat se poursuivra demain on verra
alors si le gouvernement et la majorité
qu'il soutient ont réussi à accorder
leurs violons
en tout cas ce soir à l'assemblée
nationale le rapporteur du projet le
socialiste claude evin
si l'emploi le chiffre du jour donne la
mesure du chômage en france pour le mois
de septembre 2 millions 39 mille 700
demandeurs d'emploi en données corrigées
des variations saisonnières soit une
diminution de 0,5 pour cent par rapport
au mois d'août en revanche en données
brutes les chiffres accusé une
progression de 8% par rapport au mois
précédent le ministère de l'emploi
souligne avec satisfaction une
décélération de la hausse du chômage
mais pour le cnpf il n'y a pas de quoi
crier victoire
à l'étranger l'actualité ce soir c'est
d'abord le vibrant appel à la paix que
le président du liban
amine gemayel via deux lancers à
l'assemblée générale des nations unies
pour sa première visite à l'étranger le
président libanais a eu droit à un
accueil chaleureux
philippe rochot rarement un chef d'état
a reçu un tel accueil à la tribune des
nations unies
amine gemayel étaient venus plaider la
cause du liban en demandant au monde de
l'aider à restaurer la souveraineté
nationale à refaire son armée et à
reconstruire le pays
ce qui coûtera plus de 10 milliards de
dollars la délégation israélienne n'a
pas applaudi quand il a déclaré nous
voulons vivre en paix sur notre terre
les palestiniens doivent aussi vivre en
tête et s'autodéterminer sur la terre de
palestine pour amin gemayel la paix au
liban est un préalable à la paix au
proche orient et les conditions de cette
paix passe par le retrait des forces
syriennes et israéliennes
hall
non lebanese olten comme les renault
à beyrouth les membres de la commission
d' enquête israélienne ont visité
aujourd'hui les camps de sabra et de
chatila élections municipales en grèce
le premier test électoral depuis
l'arrivée au pouvoir du parti socialiste
de monsieur papandréou
si son parti réalise un meilleur score
qu'au municipale précédente
il est cependant en recul par rapport
aux législatives un recul qui profite
surtout au parti communiste grec pro
soviétique et accessoirement à
l'opposition de droit un écrivain cubain
qui a passé plus de la moitié de sa vie
dans les prisons de fidel castro vient
d'être libéré armando valladares 45 ans
l'un des quelque 300 prisonniers
politiques qui selon amnistie
internationale sont détenus à cuba
armando valladares arrivera à paris
avant le 30 octobre
c'est une démarche personnelle du
président mitterrand par l'entremise de
son conseiller régis debray qui étaient
à l'avant de la semaine dernière qui a
conduit à cette libération
c'est une affaire douloureuse puisqu'il
s'agit d'enfants d'enfants handicapés
peut être mêlé à circuits organisés de
dépravation sexuelle
c'est aussi une affaire bien trouble les
trois ans responsable du lieu de vie le
choral c'est le nom d'un centre pour
handicapés près de montpellier
les trois responsables ont été présentés
cet après midi au juge d'instruction à
paris
ils ont été inculpés et écroués pour
attentat à la pudeur sans violence sur
mineur de moins de 15 ans et incitation
de mineurs à la débauche dans la région
les réactions sont celles de la
stupéfaction plus encore que de
l'indignation
d'autant plus qu'aucun parent n'a porté
plainte henriette charb acquis par est
certain c'est que monsieur crise un jour
alouettes auraient loué une voiture
lendemain comme si le corps a fait
couler beaucoup d'encre il ne délie pas
les langues
vraies ou fausses accusations la presse
s'interroge sur place aux chorales on
suit la sphère dans l'abattement le plus
total ce travail qu'on a fait avec les
enfants et
l'impression qu'il est que réduit
maintenant arrêt du tout que ça va être
très difficile de pouvoir refaire
quelque chose puisque avec tous eu toute
cette presse stendhal bon on est quand
même le salit éclaboussé on ne comprend
pas du tout ce qui a pu se passer
pourquoi on est mêlé à ça les ragots les
rumeurs les lourdes accusations ne
semble pas ébranler les parents qui
avaient confié leurs enfants à claude
sigala et sonic
je lui fais confiance et je continue à
lui faire confiance parce que je suis
encore ici depuis six ans je serai donc
d'un côté de lui mon fils est venu en
week end chez nous je leur avais
aujourd'hui et restera là et aucun
problème de ce côté là pour les avocats
et calomnie ne serait fondée sur rien il
s'interroge sur la personnalité du
mystérieux monsieur k dont les
révélations ont provoqué cette cascade
de gros titres
parmi les personnages et autres
personnalités qui seraient mêlés à la
faire on cite le nom d'un membre du
cabinet du secrétaire d'état madame du
foie dans une conférence de presse
aujourd'hui madame du foie estime qu'il
s'agit là d'une rumeur absurde
cela dit marcel trillât où en est
exactement l'enquète dans cette bizarre
affaire ce qui est sûr c'est que le
système juridique déclenché le 6 octobre
par le juge d'instruction 16 man semble
devoir poursuivre son cheminement
logique le juge jasmin l'on sait est un
peu spécialisé dans les affaires de
pédophilie comme celle de saint-ouen qui
récente et trois personnes où l'avez dit
qui avait été fait l'objet d'un mandat
d'amener leurs directeurs du choral
claude sigala le docteur alain chiapello
et l'éducateur jean-noël bardy viennent
d'être inculpés et incarcérés sur la
base de quels éléments de quel
témoignage de quelles preuves
la question se pose toujours aucune
plainte de parents d'enfants les
témoignages de soutien à cette
expérience originale dead à des jeunes
en difficulté sans médicalisation qui se
multiplient alors il faut revenir au
début de la faire tout a commencé par
les dénonciations de jean claude krief
qui avait séjourné quelques temps aux
chorales or ce jeune homme a lui même
été inculpé en mars 82 à clermont
ferrand pour escroquerie
les accusations de ce personnage un peu
trouble était tellement grave et les
personnalités mises en cause tellement
importante que le juge a voulu crever
l'abcès et faire toute la lumière
on parlait en effet le manque du cabinet
de georgina dufoix qui a démenti ce soir
mais aussi des ministres pour achever de
compliquer les choses on apprenait que
le frère de jean claude krief michel
tentait de monnayer auprès des journaux
un procès verbal de police accusant ces
deux personnalités on sait maintenant
qu'il s'agissait qu'il s'agissait d'un
faux et on se pose des questions sur sa
provenance
que les faits reprochés aux trois
inculpés se confirme tout pas il est
possible qu'on ait voulu à travers cette
affaire portait atteinte à une
expérience qui dérange
étant donné l'ampleur et la virulence
des commentaires on ne peut exclure tout
à fait aussi la possibilité d'arrière
pensées politiques
au moins trois morts un blessé grave et
le bilan pourrait encore s'alourdir à
metz au port céréalier un silo à grains
a explosé cet après-midi françois corner
dix ouvriers sont encore ce soir
ensevelis sous les 11 mille tonnes
d'orge contenues dans ce silo
l'explosion s'est produite vers 14h35
cellule de l'édifice de 70 mètres de
hauteur ont été détruites
gendarmes pompiers militaires du génie
chiens d'avalanche ont participé aux
recherches
mais six heures après cet accident les
sauveteurs n'ont retrouvé aucun
survivant
on s'interroge bien sûr sur l'origine de
cette explosion
aucun gaz n'alimentait semble-t-il le
silo à grains qui étaient équipés
uniquement de câbles électriques
l'hypothèse de la fermentation de l'orge
est rejetée par le directeur de la
malterie de moselle les experts quant à
eux n'ont fait pour l'instant aucune
déclaration
cette explosion d'un silo et la sixième
de ce genre qui se produit dans le monde
depuis cinq ans tuant etats-unis en
allemagne l'espagne en france 79
d'ouvriers la communauté juive française
en deuil
le baron à l'inde rothschild est mort
brutalement hier à new york d'une crise
cardiaque
âgé de 72 ans il présidait le conseil
représentatif des institutions juives de
france
longtemps à la tête du consistoire
central il avait notamment oeuvré à la
réintégration des juges d'afrique du
nord et au développement de
l'instruction religieuse
if toutes les organisations juives
françaises l'ambassadeur d'israël en
france le maire de paris entre autres
lui rendent hommage
autre disparition celle d'un héros de la
seconde guerre mondiale le héros de
narvik le général antoine béthouart
vient de mourir à l'âge de 93 ans madame
truman vient de mourir aux états unis la
veuve du président américain harry
truman avait 97 ans puisque l'actualité
ce soir se drape de crêpe noir signalons
encore que l'état de santé de l'écrivain
louis aragon 85 ans s'est brusquement
aggravée ces derniers jours il fait
l'objet de soins médicaux intensifs
un mode et soit au plus tôt des lauriers
avec l'attribution du prix nobel de
chimie qui va professeur britannique
cloud et le prix nobel de physique
attribué à un américain
alain gillot-pétré je ne vais pas vous
demander d'expliquer leurs travaux mais
par les looks plutôt du temps demain
bien écouter le temps demain sera
surtout caractérisés par une très grande
douceur une douceur tout à fait
automnale
regardez la photo satellite est très
simple à comprendre en effet sept
grosses masses de nuages se rassurent
l'est du pays donc c'est l'humilité donc
seydoux est ici voyez ça se découvrait
sur l'ouest
donc il y aura du soleil la carte pour
demain en détail sur la moitié est et
sud-est du pays beaucoup beaucoup de
nuages avec de la pluie et localement
des orages plus abondante surtout sur
les versions sud des reliefs du relief
sur la grande moitié nord ouest
débrouillards le matin bassin qui est un
bassin parisien et l'après-midi
alternance d'éclaircies et de passages
nuageux en fin de journée arrivés sur
les côtes de l'atlantique d'une nouvelle
perturbation accompagné depuis pour la
fin de la journée les températures sans
grands commentaires très très douce 15
degrés minimum 20 degrés maximum à
toulouse cela fait une moyenne nationale
de 16 degrés demain c'est le mardi 19
octobre quatre minutes de soleil en
moins levé 7h18 coucher 17h53 et c'est
là ça rené à 23h15 jacques merlino vous
présentera notre dernier journal demain
antennes de midi daniel bilalian je vous
retrouverez demain à 20 heures
bonne soirée